poll landed and the majority of the
people expressed their views by not
showing up in the polling centers the
turnout was very low all across the
country there was scattered violence as
well people we spoke to on the street
didn't want it to be in the Camara
expressed their disgust at a
non-inclusive election and one R Shar
say it
well all essential food prices are
Skyhigh we poor people are not happy
under this government we don't accept
this autocratic government or the at all
we will not recognize it we had a chance
to spoke to one of the presiding officer
in a polling Boot and this is what he
have to
say we will be able to find the
percentage of Voters later but the
presence of Voters was significantly
low the main opposition party and 16
other Alliance had boycotted this
election after months of protest and
they were under Crackdown by the
government now we'll know more within
next few days how the global Community
view this election in Bangladesh the
result is obviously quite predictable
San Chri Al jazer
Dhaka make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer